We're asked to simplify m to
the third and then that
squared all over mx to the
third all of that to the
fourth power.
And they want us to
express our answer
in exponential form.
And then they tell us that m
does not equal zero and x does
not equal zero.
Because if they did, then this
denominator would be equal to
zero if either of them
did and then that
would just be undefined.
So that's what they have to put
that little caveat there.
That neither of them are going
to be equal to zero.
So let's try to simplify this.
Let me rewrite it.
So the numerator is m to
the third squared.
And our denominator is mx to the
third to the fourth power.
Now let's just work on each
of these independently.
What is m to the third and then
that to the second power?
Well if you raise something to
an exponent, and then raise
that whole thing to another
exponent, this is going to be
the same thing.
So this numerator up here
is going to be m to
the 3 times 2 power.
Or m to the sixth power.
We're raising it to third
and then squaring it.
And if you think about it, this
expression right here--
let me just do a little
aside here.
M to the third squared, there's
no magic behind why
were multiplying that.
If you think about m to the
third squared, this is the
same thing as m to the third
times m to the third.
And if you saw something
like this, you would
add these two exponents.
3 plus 3.
You have exactly two 3's here.
If this was 4, you would be
multiplying it four times.
So you'd have four 3's.
So that's why we're multiplying
these two
numbers, 3 times 2.
So that gives us
m to the sixth.
And then the denominator here,
we have mx to the third to the
fourth power.
Now in general, when you have
the product of some numbers,
and you're raising the entire
product to some exponent, you
can raise each of the terms
to that exponent.
So this denominator right here,
this is going to be m to
the fourth times x to the
third to the fourth.
I'm just raising both of these
terms, m to the fourth x to
the third, to the
fourth power.
Now, what does this
simplify to?
Well, our numerator is
still m to the sixth.
I'll do one step at a time.
Our denominator is
m to the fourth.
But we have x to the third and
then that to the fourth power.
So we can multiply these.
3 times 4.
So this is x to the 12th power,
so times x to the 12th.
Now, we have an m to the sixth
in the numerator and an m to
the fourth in the denominator.
You can view this as the same
thing as m to the sixth times
m to the negative four,
either way.
But we know, or hopefully we
know, that this right here can
be simplified as m to the
sixth minus 4 power.
So this is going to be equal
to-- so the numerator, we
could have m to the sixth minus
4, which is m squared.
That's what this
simplifies to.
And the denominator we still
have an x to the 12th.
And we're done.
If we don't want something in
the denominator, we could
rewrite this x to the 12th in
the denominator as x to the
negative 12th in
the numerator.
So we could rewrite this whole
expression as being equal to m
squared times x to
the negative 12.
Either of these would be
an acceptable answer.